fresh mint chutney it's fantastic it's
mouth-watering is so fresh it's
absolutely delicious
this chocolate is really great so many
different things I need to put Labor's
really get your palate appetite going
nice really good start fresh clean
chutneys exciting vibrant and really
nice way of relaxing customers really
nice way that'll be the real test
hello thank you
yeah definitely still overclocked jazz
prawns white they're coming out
overcooked still as soon as we take the
prawns or I please solved in I'll ask
you to look at that seriously in terms
of attended the cooking less I think
what we need to do is every portion of
prawns that goes out this week do one
extra prawn and test it before it goes
out because that's something that we
need to work on solid back just see what
they say but I'm going to say it's not
spicing up and I'd like it a little
hotter I want to see what they do
hello settle my needle is spicy
objections question its Rick a pilot
really hot food so it's nice right it's
very mild huh
what if it possible to have a saving
water thank you very much thanks
maybe for something else that's really
kind thank you so patient so time third
time lucky thank you two dishes I love
it
no that time customers always right
that's what the painful you can adapt
the customers needs great
well farts to the end of the meal and
I'm so happy and I don't think I can
look talk to me anybody I don't handle
any better either sticking with
profession when the food arrives they
love the food when the service matches
the food you have something quite
exciting there jazz I want you to step
up to the mark
I need to do something think I'm bit
nervous right now but later on um
wouldn't wallop the confidence we will
become a valuable feedback that was
absolutely amazing we've got to be so
positive to make sure that we learn from
the mistakes my undercover evidence has
hit them hard now they need to learn
from this experience there's no time to
waste because both restaurant chefs are
about to face their biggest challenge
yet